and Advance somebody's getting knocked
out tonight in Los
Angeles LeBron sto and hit James a force
of nature drives in flips it
in 31 for LeBron
James appreciate
greatness the Los Angeles Lakers
Advance destination vac yes you took
over in the fourth quarter how much do
you live for those moments still to this
day after everything that you've
accomplished in your career well I mean
is winning time every possession in the
game counts I don't discredit what goes
on in the first quarter you know you can
lose a game early on you can win a game
late or vice versa but when the game is
close I always try to just be even more
lasered in locked in onto the assignment
um late in game and try to make plays
oh a tasty dish LeBron James what a game
for LeBron he continues to dominate
father time so I've seen bronny play
before I've seen you play in person many
times but seeing him at the son's game
watching you and every Big Moment
watching his smile and his eyes light up
how has being a father changed you
parenting and for me being a father I
mean it teaches you a lot about patience
you know it keeps you grounded you know
even more now I mean obviously the
incident that happened with my son this
summer with bronnie um in his Cardiac
Arrest um situation now let's put
everything back into perspective and
understand what's really important so to
see him when he's able to make the games
or I'm able to see him you know and see
that his eyes are wide and his smile is
bright things of that nature um you know
it's it's pretty it's pretty awesome
unbelievable the Lakers advaned to Vegas
to take on the New Orleans Pelicans the
final four no one has ever played these
games before what are the advantages
some of the things that you've seen that
these environments have brought out in
you and your teammates I think this
moment is great to prepare for the
postseason you know early on you get a
you get a feel for it even you know the
game that we just hosted versus Suns and
had that playoff atmosphere so for a lot
of guys that either have not been part
of the postseason or haven't been in
like you know the third round where it's
the Conference Finals or to the finals
that kind of had that feeling to us
we're fighting for something I think
guys are getting into a rhythm Vegas
baby
Vegas Vegas Club we're starting to
finally get healthy as healthy as we've
been all season so a lot of guys that
haven't played are eager to get back
onto the floor and and showcase what
they Brin our ball clip James kicks it
out renish Corner
three Re oh yeah oh you thought it was
going to be LeBron maybe Anthony Davis
nope greatest competitors in the world
fighting for something so let's fight
whether it's the trophy the bright light
the extra money the competitive nature
brings out with you what gives gives you
the excitement what will get you going
thinking about this opportunity anytime
you get an opportunity to do something
for the first time you know I think
that's one that's very Grand I mean I
just love to compete um you get an
opportunity to financially win some
money but more importantly you get an
opportunity just to compete at the
highest stage and you know there's four
teams left and there four teams that
love to compete so I love that shows you
what a man's really made of
[Music]
absolutely